I call for the immediate indictment of
Michael Thomas Flynn on charges of and
his immediate arrest on suspicion of
violations of the Logan Act I call for
his immediate suspension resignation or
dismissal as the national security
advisor to the President of the United
States of America I call for the
immediate investigation of whether his
relationship with the Russian government
is limited to activities covered by the
Logan Act or if he is acting as an agent
of the Russian government or as in the
past acting as a paid employee of
companies affiliated with the Russian
government I call for senators Graham
and McCain and any remaining patriotic
Americans on the Republican Senatorial
roster if any there yet be to fulfill
their promise of weeks ago to
immediately conduct a full open and
limitless investigation into Russian
hacking during the election into Russian
coordination with the Republican
presidential campaign during the
election and into the contact between
the Russians and the transition team
between the time of the election and the
time of the inauguration and lastly I
call for the grand jury to not only
indict Flynn for his alleged violations
of the Logan Act but also for those
grand jury proceedings to include the
naming of at least one unindicted
co-conspirator who may have been aware
of and may have colluded with Flynn's
improper conduct involving the Russian
government I identify that potential
unindicted co-conspirator as Donald John
Trump the specific crimes included in
the Russian meddling in our presidential
campaign of 2015 2016 and in the Russian
interference in our presidential
election of 2016 are as yet unclear but
in a series of events last week that
seemed like mere individual explosions
during a blitzkrieg of trumpian evil the
outline of what has reportedly been done
by Michael Flynn who is at this moment
still the man officially charged with
advising a reckless and seemingly
mentally unstable president on all
national security issues that outline
became substantially more clear Flynn
Lieutenant General United States Army
retired shown here on Thursday December
10 to
thousand 15 in Moscow seated at a table
with the Russian dictator Putin at a
dinner for the Russian arty television
network by whom Flynn has been paid
later scene leading a standing ovation
for Putin at the same event on Wednesday
February 8 mr. Flinn again denied that
he had privately discussed US sanctions
against Russia with Russian ambassador
Sergei kis Lac on December 29th while
Barack Obama was still president if
proven such discussions by Flynn could
be illegal interference in stated
American foreign policy under federal
statutes referred to as the Logan Act if
proven such discussions could also
indicate that Flynn misled or lied to
press secretary Spicer and vice
president Pence both of whom issued
repeated public denials on Flynn's
behalf on Thursday February 9
Flynn's spokesman changed the generals
story Flynn now quote indicated that
while he had no recollection of
discussion sanctions he couldn't be
certain that the topic never came up on
quote on the same day the newspaper of
the Washington Post cited nine current
and former holders of senior positions
in u.s. agencies with access to US
intelligence about the Flynn kiss the
act conversations including transcripts
of their phone calls according to the
paper all nine insisted quote Flynn's
references to the election related
sanctions were explicit two of the
sources say further that the
intelligence indicates Flynn urged
Russia to delay any response to the
sanctions until Trump was sworn in and
could change them on Friday December 30
2016 after the Flynn kiss lack
conversations the Russian dictator Putin
said he would delay any response to the
obama sanctions also on friday december
30 2016 the then president-elect tweeted
quote great move on delay by V Putin I
always knew he was very smart the
likelihood that Trump's message to Putin
Trump's close relationship with Flynn
and Flynn's conversations with kis lyac
are all coincidental reportedly after
and before the election is so small as
to be almost laughable and if they are
not coincidental
had guilty knowledge of Flynn's
conversations with kiss lack and if
Flynn can be indicted for violations of
the Logan Act Trump's awareness of this
crime and his cover-up of it elevates
him to the status of possible unindicted
co-conspirator with other implications
relative to presidential impeachment on
April 27th 2016 then candidate Trump
gave his first major foreign policy
speech seated in the front row of the
audience at the Mayflower Hotel in
Washington DC Russian ambassador or
Sergey kiss back as a 5:30 p.m. on
Friday February 10 a White House
official quoted by The Associated Press
said Trump has quote full confidence
unquote in Michael Thomas Flynn the
interference by a foreign power in our
government in our country is intolerable
collusion between a hostile foreign
power and representatives of our
government or representatives of a
government yet to be risks are
independent existence as a nation and
renders those who commit such collusion
if not necessarily by legal definition
than in their hearts traitors they will
be exposed rooted out of any position of
responsibility in this country and
punished to the fullest extent of the
law and that begins with the immediate
indictment and arrest of Michael Thomas
Flynn and the identification as
unindicted co-conspirator of Donald John
Trump resist peace